[Musique]
ils sont magnifiques
appétissant nutritifs on nous encourage
fortement à en manger plus mais chaque
année il se retrouve sur les liste peu
enviable des dirty dose c'est liste
énumère les douze fruits et légumes
contenant le plus grand nombre de
pesticides ce qu'on fait que beaucoup de
ces pesticides leur sont toxiques
mais ma dose relativement faibles et ils
sont toxiques particulièrement pour le
cerveau les listes des dirty dozen sont
compilées à partir de données
gouvernementale officielle par des
organismes de protection de la santé et
de l'environnement
américains européens et canadiens
o'neill samuel et toxicologue à
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec depuis plus de vingt ans il
étudie les effets des pesticides sur
l'environnement il humain qui vont nous
inquiéter davantage avec les pesticides
dans l'alimentation c'est que ce sont de
faibles doses la répétition pendant de
longues périodes et l'ordre parler
d'effet chronique donc des effets comme
par exemple le cancer des effets système
endocrinien système neurologique sur la
reproduction le développement par
exemple
maryse bouchard biologiste travail en
santé environnementale
ses plus récentes recherches portent sur
les effets des pesticides sur le système
nerveux
le testing entre dans le corps va être
absorbée dans la circulation systémique
et à ce moment l'oeuvre passer à travers
les différents organes du corps y
compris le cerveau là où il peut créer
des dommages consulte de ça il va être
éliminé par voies urinaires
on retrouve des résidus de pesticides
dans l'uriné de 90 pour cent des
canadiens les listes de dirty dozen ne
donne aucune information sur la
dangerosité des pesticides
s'ils sont interdits aussi leur
concentration dépasse les normes
canadiennes dans le cadre de son post
doctorat à harvard
maryse bouchard a réalisé une étude avec
très chercheurs provenant de sept pays
différents auprès de 1200 enfants
américains
une des conclusions les femmes enceintes
et les jeunes enfants sont
particulièrement vulnérables
ce qu'on a observé c'est que les enfants
qui avaient jeté des achats vers
davantage de risques du rnr de
pesticides
il faut dire par contre que avec une
étude comme ça on peut pas
nécessairement conclure au fait que les
pesticides sont en cause et
l'hyperactivité
il serait possible aussi qu'il ya
d'autres facteurs qu'ils soient
intervenus mais ça sonne je pense un
signal d'alerté
une deuxième étude va encore plus loin
en californie ces chercheurs en santé
publique ont suivi 270000 nouveau-né
résidant à proximité de zones d'épandage
de pesticides
rien est une qui a montré que les femmes
enceintes qui vivaient dans des endroits
où il y avait eu des pesticides qui
avait été épandue proche de la résidence
était plus réservé ce de donner
naissance à des enfants qui est ensuite
été diagnostiqués avec un trouble
autistique
d'un côté on doit manger plus de fruits
et légumes et de l'autre il y à ces
dangers associés aux résidus de
pesticides
que faire au minimum il faut les
nettoyer
en fait il faut laver à grande eau donc
faux ferrand faire couler l'eau et
frottez le fruit ou le légume soit avec
vos mains ou encore avec une brosse qui
fêtait une brosse algues - fruits et
c'est ça qui est la meilleure méthode et
après ce bien asséché qu'en est il de
tous les avons un fruit et légumes sur
le marché
il semble que le savent on n'est pas des
fils supplémentaires comparativement à
l'utilisation de l'eau seule ta grande
boucle confronte avec une brosse autres
solutions variées nos choix de fruits et
légumes et pourquoi pas opter pour des
fruits et légumes contenant peu ou pas
de pesticides qu'on retrouve sur des
listes appelé ligne fifties
on pourrait plus pendant la période on
est enceinte favoriser ses cousins
légumes là et diversifier son
alimentation si pas manger tout le temps
de temps le même produit puis je
privilégie la version biologique pour
certains les et légumes qui sont
particulièrement contaminées
l'agriculture biologique peut faire
partie de la solution
même si on y retrouve parfois des
pesticides généralement reparler de
pesticides à faible impact donc des
produits lorsqu'ils ont été évaluées ou
vos toxicologiques ont démontré un
faible potentiel d'atteindre le haut
niveau ça longtemps
par contre il faudrait vraiment pas
s'empêcher de manger des fruits et
légumes si votre budget ne vous permet
pas d'acheter du bio logique parce que
sans priver je pense qu'on fait beaucoup
plus de temps à notre santé que de
prendre des fruits et légumes issus de
cultures traditionnelles parce que si
vous n'avez pas suffisamment de fruits
et légumes où vous allez manquer
beaucoup d'éléments nutritifs
d'antioxydants
[Musique]